Roman trachomatis.
He is a
Ukrainian soldier from Kiev right now
fighting outside, back loot.
And Roman,
I know
you just returned to back
from a brief leave
and I just showed the video
you posted today from the front lines.
What has changed during the ten days
you were on that briefly
I was
I think like life in general, a change.
Fierce battles
continue for every single meters
of Ukrainian land.
So
the only thing is change.
It's me
because I was on a little rotation.
I was paradise.
And now I'm back to hell again.
I know you just posted a video
from the trenches on your return,
and I'm just going to play Roman a clip
where you
you know,
you want people watching to
to see what's happening
there, to see the trenches. Here it is.
What?
It was crazy rocket shelling here
So now
what can I say?
Living in trenches is
where a crazy filmed and
I still can't believe
that I'm not in Kiev.
I'm here in dirty and
only 47
in a very dangerous place.
Obviously, we hear the gunfire, you know,
as you were as you were just
sort of panning your your camera, Roman.
You know,
we hear so much
talk about the coming
Ukrainian counter-offensive.
Are you and your unit making preparations
or have you been told anything
about whether
what you'll be doing is changing
Yeah, unfortunately, it's
the same secret as is for you
and for us as well.
So the only guys who know
about counteroffensive president
and maybe a few people more. That's all.
And you and I have talked in the past,
you talked about wave
after wave of foreigner fighters,
you know, coming to basically be killed
because they knew if they turned around,
they would be killed for sure.
Are you still seeing that fighting method
being used by Russians?
Ah, yes.
And also there are some other Russian
or a regular army exist.
So it's it's it's
more a percentage of regular Russian army
on the
on the battlefield than than it was, you
Yes. Yes.
Because we work hard.
And after after our job, the Wagner Group
just disappeared
Like, not, not fully, but
in, in huge numbers.
Roman, I want to play a video
that you posted in
this one is very different.
So our viewers understand
this is you commenting about
finding a beautiful moment in this place.
You are right that that you say is a hell
and you're
speaking in Ukrainian in the video
I'm going to play
there are subtitles, though,
and I just want everyone to see it
all on this program.
Is so
equally is that
you said beautiful sunset
and bullets flying all around as you're
you're literally ducking.
You're in the midst of a battle.
And yet you saw the sunset.
What do moments like this mean to you?
This is this is exactly this.
This is the moment between life and death
because every every is
every second can be blessed this moment.
And I'm really glad
that I can share with you
such such
feelings and such thoughts because
this is
this is what we what we go in through
every single day on the battlefield.
And I think it's important that people
can have opportunity to know,
at least to see such videos,
how it's happened from inside the war.
How soldiers feel their
feelings on the battlefield.
Roman, thank you very much.
I know you were in the battle
battles last night and you will be
going right back.
So thank you very much
for taking the time to share
what you're seeing,
what you're going through with everyone.
Okay. Always welcome.
Thank you for calling me back.
And OUTFRONT now,
retired Army Lieutenant
General Mark Hertling
and General Hertling.
In that conversation,
you just heard Roman
talk about the counteroffensive, right?
That he doesn't know
what's going to be required of him
as a soldier. Right.
And maybe a few people do
in the country, but. Right.
He doesn't know how difficult from from
what as you look at this
is this expected counter offensive
for Ukraine going to be now?
It's going to be very difficult
and challenging, Erin,
because this phase of the campaign,
I'm calling it
phase six, is a different approach.
What you've had thus far
and this young man
has probably experienced
the attack
by the Croatian troops, the attack
by the Russians.
Yes, Russia has been on the offensive
and Ukraine has been on the defensive
when this
which is
when Ukraine goes on the defensive
or goes on the offense,
it's going to take a lot of requirements
for coordination,
cooperation, different types of movement
the defensive lines of Russia,
which I believe
some of the reinforcements
have been put into,
are going to be much
more heavily manned
and much better prepared
they've been preparing
those defensive positions
since about October.
And the offense is always more difficult
than the defense for most soldiers.
So what you're going to see
is a change in approach
or change in dynamic.
And it's just going to be different.
It's a different mission
set requiring more of the soldiers
and that's that reality
is really important for people
to understand.
You know, in this context,
Western intelligence, right,
as you know,
estimates that what, 40, 45,000
Russian soldiers
have been killed in this war.
Right. It's a stunning death toll.
But what I thought
General Crowley said
today was pretty incredible
in that context.
Even with that,
the Russian ground force
in Ukraine right now is bigger,
he says, than it was at the
start of the invasion.
And they say
the Air Force
and Navy, despite those
these Air Force mishaps, lately,
these these terrible mistakes
they've made,
have suffered minimal losses.
So what do you take away from that,
that there's more Russians on the ground
now than there were at the beginning?
It is not a surprise to me, Erin.
And as you remember,
we've talked multiple times
about something
I called Battlefield
Math about a year ago.
And when Russia entered this conflict,
they had 190,000 soldiers allegedly.
That seems like a lot.
But for the missions
they had for the various mission sets,
they were required.
That was nowhere near to be enough troop
to task requirements
for the Russian soldiers.
They realized that they've now
reinforced those positions,
especially the defensive positions,
the cities, the towns.
So they have more soldiers here.
But I'd also remind you, so does Ukraine.
Ukraine has also mobilized
literally hundreds
of thousands of people.
So this clash of an offensive against
the defense is going to be tough.
Now, General Coppola
also mentioned the Air Force and
the Navy.
He estimated
that the
Russian Air Force
has lost about 80 airplanes.
They've literally got hundreds,
if not thousands more to do.
But what we've seen
in the Russian Air Force
and the Russian Navy
is the same kind of ineptness
that their army has shown.
They have not coordinated.
They have not trained,
they're not competent on the battlefield.
So they have not used their Air Force
forward of the line of troops.
In other words,
where their front lines are,
they haven't flown Air Force beyond that
because they can't control them
and they're afraid of
Ukrainian air defense.
So, yes, the
the assessment,
the quantitative assessment
by General Campbell
is absolutely correct.
It's going to be a clash,
certainly a tough fight
in the next phase of this operation.
Right.
Of course, is as we all understand.
A quantity is not necessarily quality.
And we've seen that it's
not in this case,
even though they still have more quantity
than many may have thought.
All right.
Thank you so much,
General Hertling, as always,
I appreciate you.